okay that was it that was the entire
you've step two not much there what is
the third and most importance there what
are we going to do
yeah okay very good
I'm going to now set about proving now
that the statement if it's true for this
one will be true for the next value
along which is my K plus one so I'm
going to prove true for N equals k plus
one so I'm going to write this equation
again but for the next one over instead
of for this one so it's 5 to the k plus
1 there's the plus 3 now what will my
next line be or rather the other side of
this line I want this to also be
divisible by 4 yeah so it's gonna have
to be four times a number all right what
is that number going to be the answer is
I don't know that number over here
depends on what k and k plus 1 are there
could be anything right now so sorry I
know it's kind of alphabet suited for
the super at the moment but I still have
to introduce another protein rule relax
it's the last one this one was P I'm
gonna call the next one Q and Q just
like P has to be a positive integer okay
I promise I'm not putting any more
letters into here that's it okay let's
do this proof then 5 to the k plus 1
equals 3 equals that that's my goal now
we know what we want to do is work with
all this logic and somehow use I'm going
to highlight it in red here somehow use
this statement here write the inductive
hypothesis I want to shape my equations
so that I can make use of this because
I'm assuming that it's true so I want to
kind of refer to it in some way okay so
here's what I'm gonna do with this
statement right here's my proof I'm
gonna take the left-hand side this is a
common way to begin here's what the
left-hand side looks like at the moment
it's just 5 to the k plus 1 plus 3 now
have a look at the inductive hypothesis
5 to the k plus 3 our assumption
you say that this assumption the
left-hand side of this assumption is
tucked away in the left hand side of
this we just need to like tease it out a
little bit right for instance there's a
plus three here and there's a plus three
there so you don't have to touch that at
all right
now there's a fire to the K here where
is that hiding in there can someone tell
me a way I could rewrite this that would
make it a bit clearer yeah area okay if
we remember our index laws then we know
that that means 5 times 5 to the K
that's what the plus 1 means right
multiply it again so you can see in here
should complete the line in here is
clearly well there's five lots of five
to the case so if I just want one of
them I'm going to break this apart into
two pieces there are four of them over
here and then there's another one over
here
is that okay do you see I've just used
the right color I've just broken this
one there's five there into two Lots
there's four over here and one there a
UK with that piece of logic do you see
now where this is going to lead in terms
of my proof where that that magical four
appeared so I'm still at the end of the
line written there okay you're right
with that so what I'm doing is I'm
trying to massage the equation I'm
working with so that I can use the
inductive hypothesis the assumption
which is what I'm about to do right now
this 4 times 5 to the K is hanging out
the front but I in the middle of my
proof assumed that this 5 to the k plus
3 this survived to the k plus 3 I
assumed that that was divisible by 4 I
assumed it was a multiple of 4 so I'm
gonna substitute it for a multiple of 4
then we miss right so I've done my
substitution now to highlight because
this is a proof by mathematical
induction what am I going to do here now
that I've used the assumption I'm gonna
put big flashing lights right I'm gonna
wave a flag and I'm gonna say hey by
assumption
because that's after all what I did I
assumed that something was true okay now
are you almost there
do I do I need to push a little bit
further on this what was my goal in the
end have a look I have written it right
down the bottom here I want to show that
this thing on left-hand side is four
times a positive integer can I do that
here what would I do
can you give me one word maybe starts
with an F I'm gonna factorize right
everything has a foreigner right four
times what's gonna be left 5 to the K
plus P okay
now have a look have a look be careful
it's not just enough to say that some
number is four times something else
right because if you said there's four
times a fraction that would not be
divisible by four how do you know this
is going to be a whole number a positive
integer have a look at it carefully take
it one step at a time have a look at
this guy what do you know about P you
don't know very much about P it could be
anything but what you do know is that P
is a positive integer yes
you see now actually it is important to
put this even though it's a very minor
piece of the working what about this guy
5 to the K what do you know about K oh
that was naughty I didn't put that in
myself let's fix that K has to be like n
right and we actually said something
about earlier that it's a positive
integer so if K is a positive integer
then what's 5 to the K going to be like
here's here's a 5 to the K there's one
of them here's another 5 to the K or
another one or you know another one what
can you tell me about all of these
numbers even though you don't know how
big they are they're all going to be
positive integers right there's no way
you can get a fraction out of this how
would you get a fraction by the way if
you can get a fraction out of 5 to power
something what would you do you'd put a
negative in right like say that's but K
can't be that K has to be a positive
integer
right what could you do to make it
negative could you do anything to make
it negative no you can't exponentials
have think about the range of an
exponential it'll never go below the
x-axis so this is a positive integer
this is a positive integer what happens
when you add two positive integers
together you get another positive
integer so therefore therefore I can say
that's four times well I'm just going to
call that positive integer Q that's it
where Q is this paper right so I'm done
there's my left-hand side here's my
right-hand side
and I'm not sure if it's lady's referred
to this because she didn't have to now
for you guys but we used to have to
write this long essay down here to
explain is like three or four lines to
explain how this logic fits together but
we've now mercifully for you guys
decided no we don't need to do that
we've done all of the work all the logic
is intact all you have to say is proven
by the principle of mathematical
induction and if you're super lazy and
in a hurry you could just write PMI but
being that past generations you have to
write like 50 words here you can surely
manage three extra ones okay so I this
is rather more elegant than actually
just crunching out a whole bunch of
numbers and hopefully fingers crossed
get a pattern out of it this is
watertight because we've proven that
it's true for one that means based on
this logic here in steps two and three
that it'll be true for two and then
three and then four and on and on
forever
okay so T a P really easy acronym to
remember and my explanation used to mean
I used to bring a roll of tape into
class and stick it on the board and say
T eight PE those are your steps but now
you have even fewer to learn